one more story for you today that i
thought
really would be a nice way to end the
show today and illustrative of what's
going on here in the world right now and
why a humble guy like me who just wanted
to go out to california and make it
that's not a gratuitous use of
california by the way i'm making a point
about california um
i just wanted to go out there and make
it and i did it i did eight years there
and i did the thing you do when you go
to california i became a success and
then i fled uh but why a guy like me had
to flee
and it's not just me there are quite
literally hundreds of thousands if not
at this point at least almost a million
people who are in the middle of this
migration process we are watching a
rather extraordinary uh rejiggering of
the entire map politically culturally we
are watching the red and the blue split
i know a lot of people are upset by that
but in some ways i think there's a lot
of good arguments for it and it's
actually okay and your state should
matter more than the federal government
etc etc and there's a lot of evidence
now that this is happening all over all
over the country and it's not just
california that people
are fleeing
so we've got some info here from becker
news the evidence is now in that
authoritarian coveted policies have
become extremely unpopular since the
covid pandemic in july 2020 to july 2021
americans have fled blue states
meanwhile states that banned vaccine
mandates saw a surge in population in
the aggregate so of course you guys know
that we're going to show you a chart
here there's a map for you and just take
a look at the map and what you are
seeing basically is that all of the blue
states with some minor exceptions people
are fleeing people are getting the freak
i almost said the other f word but
they're really pushing me on that these
days they're getting out of the blue
states they're getting out of states
that are endlessly locked down
and they are moving to red states and
not only are they moving to red states
but you guys know this all of these
ridiculous politicians like gretchen
whitmer the governor of michigan and
gavin newsom
and you know up in california is that
one gratuitous i'll throw in five bucks
for that one just for saying gavin
newsom's name you know what every time i
say his name i'll throw in five bucks so
that's it so start the tally all right
um
these people vacation here
aoc vacations in florida eric swalwell
vacations in florida these people don't
believe their own policies they don't
believe their own nonsense
they want to destroy their states and i
think they're doing it quite well bill
de blasio you know people talk about
bill de blasio the socialists who ruin
new york city a lot of people are like
he was a failure look at new york city
now the homelessness the drug use the
mass migration all of the stuff and it's
like was he a failure or did he do
exactly what a socialist would want to
do i'm pretty sure that he did this is
quite extraordinary if you look at the
map conor can we pull that map up again
this is really incredible stuff
california has lost roughly 367
000 people that is a crazy crazy number
florida on the other hand and hopefully
all of these people know what they're
fleeing and what they're going to vote
for once they're here has gained 220
000 people um
like the proof is in the pudding the
proof is in the pudding right
do you know anyone because i don't do
you know anyone in your own life i would
really love to hear it please contact us
one way or another who was like you know
what i can't take it in florida anymore
with my ability to make my own decisions
uh i'm moving to new york
like it sounds ridiculous but you could
see someone being like you know i've
lived in new york city my entire life
and i've never seen more crime and it
doesn't seem safe and the businesses are
all closed and they've got these vaccine
mandates and the people who are in
charge don't even abide by them i'm
moving to florida like that does make
sense right so you don't even have to
look at the stats right i can read stats
to you but like think about your own
life think about what you're doing in
your own life think about the places you
aspire to be peop think about the places
that other people aspire to be think
about the places that people want to
leave it's like nobody actually
i do know one person who moved to new
york city
in all of the last two years and believe
it or not it was my mother-in-law
because she fell in love she actually
fell in love and the guy great guy
i'm not going to name him right here but
a really really wonderful guy
lives in new york city i don't know how
long they're going to stay there
but she fell in love and moved to new
york city so i guess strange things have
happened but the point is guys you see
what's going on here and and just to add
a little bit more on this uh there's
some info here from the daily mail in
terms of people's political leanings
changing right now as well a new survey
conducted by gallup revealed that 47
percent of americans identified as
republican or republican leaning at the
end of 2021 that's a 9
increase in support
from the start of the year so what i
thought was extraordinary about that is
it doesn't surprise me obviously that
more people are sort of leaning right
right they're going okay
the wokesters the leftists whatever is
remaining of the same liberals none of
this works the democrats are basically
all crazy liars i can't you know there's
joe manchin he's all right you got
kirsten cinema and maybe tulsi still a
democrat i don't know but there's really
just nothing left there there are no
sort of sane liberal pundits i would put
let's put bill maher on the side or okay
you can put him where you want to put
him in that there's just nothing left
over there so as i often say on the show
you don't have to be a republican
but you cannot be a democrat i don't
know that i really consider myself a
republican a republican is part of a
political party you're part of the
republican political party like i don't
need to be part of a political party per
se i think that's sort of an old-school
way of looking at things but do the
conservative set of views to the basic
ideas of freedom and rule of law
and personal choice are those a better
set of ideas than whatever the freak is
going on with this collectivist
authoritarian lunacy and this obsession
with race and gender
and state power and taxing the [ __ ] out
of you it's like the choice is yours man
and and everyone gets it